but I come on I don't want to just
deviate off the line like there's that
turn it has to be again yielding in the
target hit you just move across like
this it's not there's no yield and you
won't pull the person in so there's a
torque for me here and then this is what
goes straight it's the first year I did
try to twist but I just twisted my foot
and now you're gonna have to come
forward and then that crazy turn which
is speed no one does everyone goes like
this so the yield is boom here then this
foot just threads the needle and your
inner knee
so again the geometry twist 45 to go on
to attack straight in boom and you have
that inch to inch off the line of attack
and your DD and we'll put it as this is
an abstract like this a lot of your
first initially in absorptions have to
have a deception out of it so if you
make your roof traverse the map it's too
easy to tell because is he's a predator
with his eyes in front of his head and
he can read death very easily okay so
you're doing your your hidden move and
you're over here she's gonna really
sense that even though I got off the
joke I didn't pull him in which is what
I want okay and as you try to do that
error what ends up happening is you
really overshot here you're really off
balance this is not a good thing so just
like if we were doing Oh she'll attempt
on I don't want to bring my center of
gravity between my legs because he's
going to sense that depth change but
there's the first
DC and nitrogen at that first move my
hip my spine didn't really traverse
across the mat because it turned on
himself you see
and then the this leg comes shot well
same thing here during in move should
happen more in place Warren place more
in place my kiss don't make it go
forward turn your hips in place then you
okay try to get okay so just
biomechanics so I can't leave my rear
heel there's no balance here
[Music]
just like in the other move as my hips
rotate they can't rotate in place so and
Sheila Ted common a rotate him in place
and watch no violence there was a weight
shift and had to happen right so I had
to go to a single pivot home when I'm
here like that so my ex rotated and I am
pivoting and weighted over this way I
can hang out there all day same kind of
thing so to do that is my hips rotate
boom I have to take that rear heel off
the ground I don't know why I do people
you guys just go crossovers everyone
knows how to take the heel off the
ground we've talked about in here many
times
so you're here boom a guideline if you
want your rear knee is lightly touching
the material of your hockey boy your
deep pan you can feel it the nest of the
threading that you would use to come in
it's the same thing if I wanted to hit
him in the groin and I didn't want to
have to aim I would just turn oh and
thread the knee through you see this leg
as a science you understand so first
move we're starting to shrink it just
here
but that yellow on the stock like cumin
has to come down okay try to get which
you I don't have assumed never to go
around.we your date okay so let's have
the other foot forward like be doing see
so here we are
twist off its some of you are not going
to turn up to the line we chat can you
see that I'm going to come in
[Music]
start asking yourself how much is my
teacher moving off the line of attack
now because some of you are like and you
just bring it right there you see and
then you're right there boom here boom
freed it hit the mandible with the way
you're supposed to don't get your thumb
out there like that then this is just
dorky okay boom then have the right
alignment which is what I did want to
work on today so do you see what's wrong
with that
that's outside my outer rim take the
move out of the way you see that you
okay when we do the technique you can
see that a lot that's incorrect
you should have weapon elbow knee hip
foot back hip back like bomb hitting you
see the line okay so we're going to use
social firemen to make sure we have the
right tactical entry angle so whoa wrong
wrong boom you should be right in that
position okay all right let's go okay so
I'll give the man you does this scheme
and I'll do the mediation the deviation
just follows my shoulders so look at my
hands that Joe is going to be even with
my shoulders is my Houser doing this you
see don't move your Joe left to right
hazardous going up up but with my body
twist
I get that angle of deflection so warm
there's no reps off target it is man so
make sure you get your hand out of the
grip don't miss
so let's look at type of lingo so
remember the first balance on the first
ballot is this way take a centre between
saving here he'll bring some boom and
take that energy just attack just a
child so what do I mean by that
this is that's not a tad okay leave it
that's it that was it
let's try it okay so we have the same
table is always when you go to hit the
hand be right I want to buy commute I
like this hit to him remember what I
said the Joe goes in line with your
shoulders you're having
well it's my hips returning my shoulders
go online with - which way is it Joe
actually going to say good Greece is
equal like that did my hips turn this
hip way which direction look at it so
which way is your boy back just like
time I go not go like that letting his
push go so when he goes it's going this
way there's that element to it it's not
that it's the same I jump in it and I
use that energy room to take me right
but don't say I want this that's not it
either
this small
[Music]
because what I wanted to do going
forward obviously if you reverse
engineer and if I'm in him backwards he
is supposed to be coming forward as I'm
doing this technique he's not sitting
there waiting for me so I don't think
he's gonna hit full penetration I had
eyes tunnel things so I still don't
think so okay
you see stay where you are buddy
do you see how he did it okay then I add
to that this guy he like the weapon just
comes here for training I'm keeping it
short so my nurse is too dangerous but
Shawn you're not you're just stuck okay
there was the stat there was a movement
change in the Joe so as I go here whoa I
already brought it in this is wrong
do you see my body alignment so if he
give me a thrust line right here
which would be the target line and he
pushes on it
so give me the spine position okay so
I'm here like this and you're too
concerned about foot sometimes I see the
beginner do kids are like well he's
foots there all right let's do this one
do you understand that his the target
would be a resistance line a force line
okay so give me that line again as you
see and I'm gonna have to use muscle
here to get this I do the other line if
my weapon is leading is his foot gonna
be there no do you understand so don't
let that foot manipulate you into some
crazy-ass geometry here whoa if you have
to for safety sake he's not taking your
candy you get it and that foot and
you're like well I'll go up high I would
prefer to see you realign for the
correct body alignment right than to
adopt this incorrect warmth
here just say Fionn it up here this is
incorrect here
okay let's go okay we're gonna kami and
again the problem is that you're losing
consciousness that's the problem but
we're going to handle it technically got
it but you're losing consciousness
meaning you're not staying up of the
present copy it up
hey so he's gonna do the technique did
he not move towards me okay so it's that
you're in you're okay
go slow smooth here's what you guys are
doing Oh where's your cut from do you
understand when we go fast guess what
you're gonna get knocked the out
okay so as she goes with his body you
see should use the technique kind of
slow city paper I stay in know the truth
today
Hey
you
[Music]
pick it up pick it up pick it up it
means not doing the same speed watch
watch how I am I still no I'm not
this hand is striking a boom so I don't
want to reach your hands I read one hand
this hand is to support hand so don't
move - hands in the middle of trying to
do its keep okay alright so let's look
at this tactically if he's coming
forward right that's what's allowing me
to stop his head and get a Kazushi angle
business weight is going forward copy
that this life coke you hope so
Koval has got him waiting there and then
I shove them backwards he's allowed to
keep going forward that way you check
his base of support with the forward
inertia so this technique cannot be hit
waiting there for me this is too long
that's not going to happen
wait he's coming forward okay so that's
what we're going to worry about so
Candy's going to be very important so if
I go to their hold too late you see me
stand in them some rules so what happens
get scared they stop see you got it you
gotta knock close the gap okay so you're
gonna make the mistake as they make
their mistake you make your mistake and
you start going towards them right
that's not what you do just like poke a
hole you can let them come to you
so I where I'm hanging out here to the
last second
who is when I do this then I get a
little extra on the second little tap
there okay not good enough then keep it
safe don't do the full weapon but this
is wrong
oh okay careful if your roof is hot all
the time that you ain't gonna trade that
way with that new kid okay
you
wrong body alignment we're not going
backwards she's standing there waiting
it's not gonna happen so you have to
absorb more less step in please by
alignment so the hand change was late
reject you up I do hit him that wouldn't
come out of your hands you're coming
around your head this is not a solution
you know you're very lucky now you lost
your mind
Bravo linemen look at how pretty that is
all right get your foot down or step
more in which is preferable
[Music]
I don't do three good then one bad go
again you got corrected to your hand
changes jacking you up and your training
too gentle let me at this point
[Music]
okay you gotta hit the thing it's not a
pose for pictures at the end no gasps
Roden where that joechip touched up
right in the face dude you're a me down
[Music]
you're aiming down your below her head
you're also below her head said this is
not real training
this is cosmetic you're below
her head
do you understand what I'm saying you
hear you below her head
it's too slow and you got the same
problem I have to aim it at her face
[Music]
we have that you got to bring that foot
around or you got to step more in I
would prefer more in she's just standing
there that that's our whole mission
right now
there you go does everyone understand
overtraining we're using the yen and the
angle of deflection to hit them as
they're coming in go get your head
checked
let's go get the mission
get your body too long it's a trick them
the twist dance is transitional you move
right through it where you went forward
you got that goofy geometry
get your heels down you stepped in to
three steps back this idea of you coming
in and me hanging out here this is where
your your lower consciousness goes no no
way you off then I feel it
it's right about here
like I don't want to be here anymore and
so you set up the preference and behind
the conference is the dichotomy him
versus me you see and you go into threat
mode and now my job is to survive
because I am part animal and you trigger
me with dread myself takeover by
Motocross mistakes over and I have to
survive now I can't do this technique I
do y'all on y'all so he goes on right or
what you did he won too because this
this thing's crazy
that's just absolutely that's it because
you're operating that threat and
survival alone so we'll go back to slow
and we're take away your weapons and put
your hands behind the box so you feel
more vulnerable if it's up to your
partner to do a slow but steady no
Turkey the Gherkin gives their
consciousness time to be intellectualize
and I'm just here and I'm practicing
releasing all the tension releasing all
the tension I don't we don't even care
about the last day you'll feel the
tension release it just by a corpse pose
you feel the tension release it you're
gonna feel the emotional tension that
the seizing the resistance you get it
you're gonna feel it conscious relax
release conscious keep my hips in place
turn
okay let's go can you miss something
yes something okay because it's not a
laser right so at this rate is it
penetrating me no it's not touching you
okay so to go like this is to practice
the fear consciousness so I am releasing
and I only move to keep my balance so if
I go good keep doing you're gonna do
your role of slow and steady but full
slow steady full okay and we're gonna go
since I said to let it touch me what was
wrong too much I'm starting to displace
you see that so IP beads communion so
his energy here is what's turning me not
me dat not me going like this
okay try to get your heel with two down
Henry
so--that's unconsciousness you can
that's fear consciousness there start
you take too much the young energy has
already changed better
you too early again that's fear
consciousness
[Music]
so you're trying to like find the
mountain temple do you know what I mean
you're like I'll relax but I'm gonna
totally zone yeah
okay stay present in the technique okay
relax already
don't wait wait don't release Virginia
release see you did it again your eyes
it's over there we don't believe in
Mountain temples these awakening in the
world not on the mountaintop that's why
you can't just train so we're gonna so
what I'm seeing is of course I saw I
will actually make you disappear so you
do two technique and then you kind of go
unconscious that's the only way to relax